john smoltz calling the games with Jill
buck Major League Baseball on Fox Johnny
of course a Hall of Famer and probably
short on sleep John good morning thanks
for joining us when you're calling the
game last night do you sort of have that
same intensity broadcasting it as you
did as a pitcher yeah you know the thing
is like you're trying to anticipate what
could happen who's going to be able to
step up
what's the manager thinking and how is
this game going to end and there's no
way that you could ever anticipate it a
game like that when it started there's
no way can it ever anticipate it the
comebacks
I just credit though I mean I really
I've never seen a game like that I've
never seen offense and ha and all and
the hitters adjust and and it was just
an unbelievable offensive game and a
classic that unfortunately somebody had
to lose but you were generally
considered to have taken part in the
greatest World Series in recent history
and that was the Braves in the twins has
this one past that already yeah in a
different way because you know when you
think about the pressure of doing
something in one particular game now
this wasn't the clincher obviously
there's still room for one team making
you know one team having the opportunity
to come back and win the series I've
never seen a game where the emotions
were so incredibly draining and there
were so many moments where you could
just you know basically hang your head
you just sense that that each team was
hanging on like a thread and and I
having known going through games like
this and knowing what it's like to one
sit and watch a game to be in a game
there wasn't there wasn't anybody in
rhythm there wasn't anybody that felt
like that this game was was well in hand
that once they came in you knew they
were locking it down Jansen didn't it
was not able to come in a game with the
lead so that changes everything and like
I said managing this game had to be an
emotional roller coaster and and no one
seemed like they could go to a solution
that was going to
to be feel great about it more surprised
at Kershaw or Keiko last night you know
more surprised at Kershaw III can only
imagine what that feels like in the
sense that that he had the game twice in
a situation where that's why I've always
said and I said you know numbers can be
incredible and information can be great
but on a given night
it doesn't always fall in hand the way
it would over 162 games and he had a
hard time putting away hitters after
long innings when he was in rhythm and
Keiko was in rhythm in game 1 that is a
fun pitching environment that was an
incredible kiss game and they both
mentioned how in rhythm and in tune
every 5 minutes they were kitchen
there was a 21 minute in between innings
19 minutes there was so much that
disrupt the rhythm that I felt that that
was part of what can get you off your
game a little bit and when the Astros
made him work in that inning obviously
where there was throughout and he
struggled to put guys away you could
sense the frustration and and look when
your hand when you're asking your
bullpen and you go to the whip as many
times as these teams have had to do it
and on short rest it's hard to be fresh
and it's hard to be efficient and we saw
that for guys just kind of gutting it up
going in there and they just didn't have
this stuff yeah and the Dodger bullpen
looks gassed we're talking to John
Smoltz the Hall of Famer he called last
night's game for Fox tomorrow night
Verlander versus Hill your MVP of the
series so far - it could be any of its
gonna be an offensive guy and you know
Bergman's had five consecutive RBIs in
the World Series you've got you take
your pick from either side what
Bellinger's been able to do I'm not
necessarily make it him the MVP but
Correa Springer it's gonna be an
offensive guy and and whoever is able to
continue that offensive success look for
to be much more limited in game six but
but that day off today is gonna help
Reese had a lot of guys that pen holy
cow I mean you know I having good
in both positions and been exhausted I
was thinking about in that game my last
game as a reliever
was in that Stadium and I pitched three
innings in relief against Houston in
Game four only for us to lose in Game
five you're exhausted and I can only
appreciate what each guy was able to do
even though they didn't get it done
the way they wanted you know this at
this point in the season
adrenaline is is the only thing that
keeps you going
are those baseball's different than the
regular season baseball you know like I
said last night I trust the pitchers who
have the the baseball's in their hands
because that's what you do for a living
and if some of them you know really feel
like there's a difference and it affects
the way that that not only it may come
off the bat or or out of your hand you
would know and I I've probably thrown
over 300,000 baseballs and when I had
one in my hand I didn't feel good at
threw it back and I I I can only say
that this is like I said last night it
literally hurts when I put a baseball in
my hand because my body starts feeling
really uncomfortable that I might throw
it again I haven't had a I haven't had
one in my hand for a long time for
obvious reasons but there's some there's
some pictures around the league whether
it came from the blisters you know from
the seams being different to the way
that maybe in the World Series now some
of them have have complaints so I gotta
trust the pitchers do you think John
know the baseball would purposely alter
these baseball's to increase no no
absolutely not know whether or not it
came from a different batch or for
whatever reasons you know how they they
they get to that point no I don't think
at all and and I know that baseball has
consistently said in the research that
they don't find any finding so this time
and and you know it's kind of like this
we're in an era now where sign stealing
has everybody paranoid and maybe to this
degree III think that there's something
but to what degree I have I have no idea
have you been to bed
yes a couple times I've got up
III was called in I thought the phone
rang and I was I was coming in the game
by the way fritzy would you like to
apologize to John officially here as you
you text him during the game to see if
he'd come home this morning
say the smoke sees the greatest like
literally between innings he's taking
the time to respond to my text not
knowing how busy was gonna be running
after the game so that was extremely
cool to say he'd come on this morning
with us thank you John no problem do you
do you hear from anybody else like
former teammates who text you during the
game oh all the time yeah I mean you
know I'm a multitasker you know during
that game I'm I'm sweating out the Lions
and their five field goals and no TV so
you're keeping an eye on the Sunday
football game and I'm doing football and
I'm keeping an eye on the baseball game
give me an idea who did you hear from
last night during the game that would
surprise us uh that would surprise you
my mom she kept saying she wanted to
take a ride on the train mom Oh see if I
can arrange that for you yeah that's
good hey safe travels thanks again and
I'm sure Fritzi bother you somehow
during Game six no problem four more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]